- STEVE?
[gunshots,
animals stampeding]
- [slurring]
DAMN IT!
COME BACK HERE,
CHIPYUNK!
FIGHT LIKE
A MAN!
- HEY, STEVE!
STOP IT!
- WHY?
THERE IS NO GOD.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE?
- THE DIFFERENCE IS
YOU'RE NOT DYING.
[sighing] THE DOCTOR CALLED
LAST WEEK AND TOLD ME.
I JUST DIDN'T TELL YOU
BECAUSE I--I REALLY--
I REALLY LIKE
THE NEW STEVE.
- BULLSHIT!
YOU'RE JUST LYING TO ME
SO I DON'T
BLOW BAMBI'S BRAINS OUT.
[gun cocking]
- WAIT, STEVE!
OKAY! OKAY!
OKAY.
SU--SUPPOSE
YOU ARE DYING.
IS THIS REALLY HOW YOU WANT TO
SPEND YOUR LAST FEW DAYS?
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I'M WASTING PRECIOUS TIME.
- THANK YOU.
- THERE'S WAY MORE MESSED UP
SHIT I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO!
[upbeat big band music]
♪
REALLY?
- ANGEL DUST!